Let's first start with these claims of civilians
and soldiers captured.
How many people by the IDF's count have been
captured by Hamas?
>> A very severe morning here in Israel and
a combined offensive by Hamas, ground, air
and sea.
Numbers are still not clear.
The numbers are substantial.
A very severe morning and we are very much
focused on saving forces.
Where there is ongoing fighting and handling
these terrorists.
Hopefully by the end of the day there will
be no more live terrorists inside Israel.
>> I think many are wondering how this happened.
There is also video of the
[8:06:48 AM]
There is also video of the border fence being
destroyed.
Do you agree that this was a massive intelligence
failure and if you could explain how this
unfolded?
>> So again from the perspective we are not
focused on that.
I'm sure this will be talked about a lot.
We will talk about what happened intelligence
buys after.
Hamas has been threatening for years.
Sometimes it's just talk.
They are a terrorist -- initialed their intentions
this morning.
A full course invasion.
People are coming on the ground with trucks.
We are fighting now to get control back in
the settlements.
>> The latest number we have from the IDF
on rockets being fired is 2000 which is a
few
[8:07:51 AM]
fired is 2000 which is a few hours old.
Do you have an updated number for us
>> It crossed the 3000 line and it was a vast
-- this morning.
They are still firing.
>> What about the civilians there on the ground.
The civilians who are under attack.
We have reports of civilians being fired at.
We have videos of a car being fired at and
we know that a tank was seized from the video
we have seen on social media.
What is being done to secure those residents
in the civilians who are being seen right
now in southern Israel.
>> We have special forces going to each one
of these locations where there is fighting
and as we speak there are firefights to take
control and clean the area where we have terrorists
[8:08:52 AM]
area where we have terrorists that came in
and did what we did.
There was a very good update there.
>> One thing is this is one division and we
have sent in more forces and commanders and
were taking the security back to the communities
there and again, a very bad morning.
You are seeing the pictures.
>> You have an estimate of how many reservists
have been called up?
>> Tens of thousands.
>> I would tell you a lot of my friends -- across
the board.
Everyone knows this is a dire
[8:09:53 AM]
Everyone knows this is a dire moment.
>> Quickly can you tell us the number you
have of how many have been confirmed dead?
>> I cannot tell you exact numbers.
It's a substantial number.
>> What we know about those infiltration routes
and what's being done to secure those and
to track them down so the country is secure?
>> First of all we are fully deployed and
focused on air coverage to see what's happening.
We deployed forces to the infiltration points
and again we are slowly securing the area
and trying to take care of all these people
that came in.
>> I will accept the answer on both.
They are substantial as it relates to the
number of dead and the number of those captured
but I want to get clarity.
When you say you cannot tell us , you cannot
tell us because you were choosing not to give
[8:10:53 AM]
you were choosing not to give the specific
number or at this hour you are not certain
of the specific number?
>> Because I'm in charge the idea and the
exact data.
>> You say the number of rockets is approaching
and of course Americans know that Israel is
not is equipped with the iron dome.
How many of those have hit their targets and
have not been intercepted by the dome?
>> They are doing a good job.
Some of the rockets that came through were
actually debris falling from -- and they have
done a good job.
We are deploying more capabilities.
Also we are looking up north making sure that
we are ready
[8:11:54 AM]
making sure that we are ready also in the
north because it conversions or other things
coming from the north and right now they are
doing a good job.
>> You confirm any attacks made by hamas and
by air or by those paragliding in?
>> They came Paraguay into Israel from the
ground forces.
In order to land --. It wasn't like a you
ev or something attacking --
>> How many villages are not under the control
of idf?
If you can't give us a number, how many or
is it a pretty big number that are not under
control?
>> So again, there's not much control.
[8:12:54 AM]
control.
There is fighting going on.
Special forces are engaging.
We mentioned a few.
There is a base and there are many locations
and we have firefights and terrorists coming
in and people harmed and right now we are
fighting to bring the situation back to a
stable state.
>> I hear the expedition and adjust the clarity.
You say that some of what hit the ground was
debris from rockets that were intercepted
by the dome.
Have there been rockets that have penetrated
the dome and hit their targets on ground?
>> There was a direct hit.
I still don't know what happened.
Probably more to come once I know we are updating
this.
And there was one this -- we always say it's
not hermetic
[8:13:58 AM]
always say it's not hermetic defense.
Hamas always tried to saturate our systems
and create divergences.
Not only with using ground forces but also
saturating -- in multiple directions.
To include in a holy day firing at Jerusalem.
>> We are talking about close to 3000 rockets
in single digits this far.
Rockets that have hit their targets.
How many fired back in retaliation into gaza?
>> Right now the air force is acting in gaza
to take care of the --.
We are responding to this inhumane attack.
>> I want to ask you about your next that
if there is one.
[8:14:58 AM]
next that if there is one.
Considering that there is no specific trigger
to these attacks by hamas this is also coinciding
coincidence or not with the yom kippur war
anniversary.
Are you expecting or concerned of another
attack coming from the north or something
with Lebanon or Syria?
>> I wouldn't give them the credit of comparing
it to the war.
They stand behind their words.
And yes we are looking at the north.
We saw some sort of conversions after they
-- and we are ready also in the north case
there is a Palestinian faction.
In case they decide to come into this we will
be ready.
Something we are looking at and
[8:15:59 AM]
Something we are looking at and we are ready
for it.
>> Where there'll be substantial ground forces
going into gaza beyond the aerial attacks
that we have seen will he be going in on the
ground?
>> I will leave that to our prime minister
and chief of staff talking about all military
options and still not
-- as we say.
Do you agree with this assessment from some
people that this is your 9/11?
You make that comparison?
>> I will leave these big questions of narratives
and events in historic comparisons to we get
our security back.
>> Colonel what is your message to the residence
there?
People
[8:17:02 AM]
to the residence there?
People who are in fear for their lives and
concerned about their safety.
One will help come and of course also angry
by the fact this even happened.
>> Idf is a people's army.
All our boys and right now being deployed
there.
They are fighting to get safety back into
these places and again is not only the soldiers,
it's also the brave communities there.
There was a community leader that got shot
and killed and each community has reservists
that when ere is a security event they deploy
and also risk their lives so right now as
we we are fighting.
If we do this interview will have a more so
holistic picture